you've got a video there which I wanted
to ask you about how um to test a
woman I've never heard that phrase
before being a Brit yeah um but why do
you think so many people are asking for
this content on
um you know women and dating where's
this all come from do you think
things come from a lot of areas I think
that
I mean there's this there's this
prevailing notion today that our
granddads had to work half as hard for
women that were twice as good as what we
have available to us today
right women today have social media and
even an average looking woman with
filters and good makeup and lighting and
a push-up bra can put out good
photography on an Instagram and get the
attention of a lot of people they can
use good photography on dating apps and
get the attention of a lot of guys
um women get far far more matches and
attention on dating apps than what men
do today
um about 80 percent of the women are
struggling to get the attention of the
top 20 percent of guys and that means
the rest of the guys are pretty much
invisible I mean if they're a seven or
eight out of ten or lower they're going
to struggle to get the attention of
attractive women that they want to be
with in today's world
so there's a lot of
I mean this is a large puzzle with
hundreds of pieces
and it's really difficult to know where
to start but it seems obvious to me at
this stage that the reason why people
have an appetite for this information is
because what they've been given their
entire lives hasn't worked they've been
told just be a nice guy be a shoulder to
cry on like how many guys do you know
that try to win the affection and the
love of a Woman by entering the friend
zone They just try to be their friend
and then when that completely goes
sideways and then she runs off to try to
be with Mr exciting and Mr reliable
sitting there with his hands in his
pocket playing pocket pool wondering why
she's with Chad you know that night
instead of him so I think I think men
and women in general not just men but I
think men and women have been let down
and lied to as far as what the other sex
responds to
and gets the results to where they're
looking at that are aligned with their
goals you know if I can put it that way
hmm and what are those wounds in the
relationships that you've had that
you've been able to turn into this
education
well I think I think divorce is is
certainly one of them you know I talked
about it in my book I have a chapter in
my book on why smart men don't marry
today
um
so
anybody that hasn't been divorced
doesn't know this but you tend to sort
of approach it from the angle of
right I found somebody I love she loves
me we've met each other's family we've
traveled we're going to take some vows
together and sickness and health and
richer and poorer and blah blah blah and
all that sort of stuff and we'll raise a
family we'll be together forever and
ever until Kingdom Come sort of thing
but it doesn't always work out that way
and marriage as a proposal for Matt
because when you get married today you
essentially invite the state into your
home
they become the governors of your
relationships they become the governor
of your assets they become the governor
of what happens to you your access to
your own children if you have to untie
the knot so
things have changed dramatically and
it's it's very difficult it's it's
misunderstood and you don't understand
it until you go through it and that's
when the fog of war is lifted and you
see what you deal with so I mean if you
took a classroom full of graduating
students from high school
um and let them sit in a divorce court
for an afternoon to watch how fathers
got treated I think you'd probably find
if you interviewed them afterwards
there'd be a lot of interesting
conversations and surprises that they
would want to talk to you about
um but it's one of those things that
there's not a lot of conversations about
today
and so why don't smart men get married
now then
there's not a lot of benefit to it you
know at this point in time when it comes
to Western marriage
um it's high risk and generally low
reward for men it's low risk and high
reward for women women tend to marry
across and up on the socioeconomic scale
they've always done that that's why
women are called hypergamous so
that's not a a bug it's a feature of
women if they didn't marry competent men
if they didn't invite competent men or
want to reproduce with competent men the
chances of them surviving or their
offspring surviving would be quite low
so women tend to marry
men of a higher caliber than themselves
that's why it's common for a forty
thousand dollar a year hairdresser to
marry uh Steve the VP of the sales team
at the large uh Fortune 500 company
um so if the knot needs to be untied
she's going to be well looked after
family law takes care of it
unfortunately it's it's structured in
such a way that it actually motivates
women to behave quite badly if they have
to untie the knot because if they go for
control which is custody of the children
then they get more money so not only do
they get the benefit of decision making
unilateral decision making without the
father contributing to that they also
extract wealth and resources from him
over a prolonged period of time and what
you what guys usually find out happens
during that period of time is they're
alienated from their own children while
their wealth is stolen from them and
given to the mother and now we have this
problem today where most most kids
growing up and you know when I say most
it's not all but it's about 43 percent
because I think the last time I saw the
stats on it but about close to half of
households are single parent households
which means that there's one parent
doing most of the child rearing and in
that case it's generally speaking
mothers because they get custody orders
about 80 percent of the time still and
that's only for married couples there's
of course you know mothers that become
single mothers whether by choice or by
accident but they go off on their own
and they raise the kids by themselves so
you've got this entire generation now
that's being raised with the absence of
masculinity in the household
and that's very problematic so back to
the original question of why aren't
smart men getting married
they're not
it's not that they're not having
children it's not that they're not
you know passing on their name and their
DNA they're still finding ways to do
that it's just they're not doing it
under the guise of marriage anymore
they're they're using prenuptial
agreements they're using contractual
Arrangements they're using relocation
geo location and move to places where
laws aren't hostile towards fathers
that's how smart men do it now
so if there's a man with a woman and the
woman's putting some pressure maybe or
wants to get married to the man I'm
looking at someone behind me but I'm not
going to mention his name and maybe this
person you know wants to still be with
the woman but doesn't want to get
married how does he navigate that
situation you just have to be firm you
have to be Resolute you have to put your
foot down and say I love you to bets and
I want to be with you for a very long
time but I do not want to invite the
state into my household I do not want to
let the government decide what happens
to our relationship to our wealth to our
children and all of those things
and realistically if she's a good woman
she should be okay with that she should
be absolutely fine with that the only
time that women absolutely lose their
mind and get upset over it is if they're
not there for the right reasons if
they're there for you because they love
you and they want to be with you and
they want
to be a part of your life whether or not
they have access to your wealth after
things don't work out or whether or not
they have access or full rights to the
children after things don't work out
shouldn't matter a good woman would be
happy to just leave with what she came
with I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the
full-length podcast you can find that
over here that clips from if you're new
to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out